here we are back get it again amnesia
I have not seen this menu in so long and
it's so nostalgic it's a wonderful menu
I thought instead of just doing that new
game we'll do an old custom story this
one is called sealed you are sealed
stuck into your house you cannot get out
nor can you escape your nightmares
prepare to get scared well we'll see
about that I wonder if this is still
scary I wonder what is that noise it
sounds like bugs or something else I
better get my lantern no game look
fantastic I loved it
hi penny it's me mr. chair the game had
a wonderful engine I gotta say that it's
so fun to just mess around with all
right where's this goddamn lantern for
real though where is it I feel like I've
sold every single puzzle you could no
I'm not gonna go there all right that's
not where's the [ __ ] light
sheriff check if it's safe okay it's god
damn it's dark I forgot how dark the
game is they really did a great job on
that the light system you don't see it
in a lot of games because you can't see
very far there she
every cap you have the land your best
friend you use those and I miss this
game
it said I don't test all the PewDiePie
memes are coming out 20 2012 teams huh I
need a key to get past here apparently
my god
whoa okay okay okay all right I trust
you now oh [ __ ] sorry what do I do wrong
what did I do wrong I'll put you here
just to make sure you're safe too fat I
know you can't get oil from this club
hey gun okay now we can go perhaps now
we can [ __ ] I should try what this is an
amazing catch no sir you're a nightmare
man
it means you're sleeping but beware you
can still die oh look a giant corridor I
wonder if anything is going to get
thrown into my face perhaps let's check
it out and you can lean to the scales
law man the memories
Oh shake
oh [ __ ] crap but it's still scary
it's the [ __ ] sounds man the sound is
incredible
ah let me go
four five oh [ __ ] then we go Gary what
the [ __ ] dammit this is the 27th night
27th very specific but I didn't get any
sleep at all he continues I'll turn
insane I need the Biblia that family so
much respect for chairs in this game all
right come in with me mr. chair if
that's even your real name wishes carpet
I know there's a key under one of the
carpets in the game man should I just
replay the original amnesia
I really want to do it cuz it takes so
long it builds up for like 40 minutes
maybe I'll just do that
all right what is this custom sorry man
can I go here it's long how memories
there she is
Easter day here I have to like no very
classic love the menu so simple it's
brilliant
this game really is brilliant there she
is very suspicious oh [ __ ] what I
remember this is one of the things about
amnesia that was so different
you couldn't really die stepfather so
for those who you don't know this guy
was like my main guy a [ __ ] statue
and then developers like doing the
custom mutts they would put it
everywhere in the game as a little
Easter egg the father I didn't know he
was in this one that's hilarious
where have you been totally it's been 84
years there you go don't worry bro ah
[ __ ] never mind
so
it was me that killed your son of a
[ __ ]
dad damn it I've been tricked
Oh God it's jumping I'm financially oh
it's my sanity those love I [ __ ] ate
20:17 pull the pipe it's the worst pour
teapot you changed me every go oh nice
nice headstand there buddy you really
got it going for you I've been stuck in
this game they shoot the game if I
should do this hole Lydon add an atom
out of them lot laudanum lot laudanum it
was it's not that hard to say feelings
wow you're really grown a lot feeling ah
there we go
take the sanity pushing don't keep
[ __ ] collapsing
what's happening
game is loading again Oh God we're in
nightmare mode again the fun
where did you go I loved you God boxes
incredible barrels my good old friends
how are you it's been a long time I love
you so much my favorite barrels are the
best to remember the phonic is like the
game just happened to have a physics
system where you can interact with
objects cuz the game really doesn't have
much else that just somehow made it so
[ __ ] popular for YouTube videos
pretty good come with me mr. barrel
very weirdly placed carpet I feel like
that's like let's have a look here what
I miss huh maybe yeah maybe I see you on
one of these Oh slab okay I've hidden
the key in this room under one of the
barrel those [ __ ] bathroom whatsit
you what's it you what
oh they're chilling here man
jeez the men having to hide from the bro
that's actually where bro came from cuz
I gosh I kept calling him bro hey bro
you got a great ass bro
[Music]
I hope you bros aren't sisters I'm sorry
looking at this like oh man look at him
now he's not even scared or all this
[ __ ] I want this to be sort of
reminiscence I'm just gonna go through
nah fam
ah [ __ ] he broke the door well he didn't
see me somehow so that worked out wait
mr. fam of course how could you forget
about my favorite character of all time
mr. Barrow go oh hell no
it's still really scary because the
sound is [ __ ] awesome I never
realized that before I thought I thought
it was there
the monsters but I guess this
combination of each with Dan we're
getting some more huh
Bing Chase is self scariest [ __ ]
Eastern whole attic key anyone entering
this house must remain for a great evil
lies in way to devour anyone into its
dark cruel grip of thousand nightmares
nothing's I remember another thing with
all the custom mods is that that really
bothered me a lot was and I didn't
really acknowledge it at the time but I
feel like now I can say it just cuz you
can make a good mod doesn't mean you can
right ok just because you're a game
developer doesn't mean you're a [ __ ]
writer Jesus Christ people would put
like essays in the goddamn notes and
they were so bad so bad god
I'm not saying I could do better but
Jesus right I was I and people got so
pissed you're not reading the notes I'm
like why would you put all these doors
in here if they're all long oh this is
where we came from what I missed it
it is sort of charming that to revisit I
like it is there's every single door
locked it brings you to the third point
of this game which is the puzzles they
did a really good job in the original
game of balancing you know the intense
moments with puzzles that were really
fun and and still immersive to explore
but I found a lot in custom stories I
would still have a key okay I don't know
which door it goes to you get stuck in
the custom story and you just get kind
of annoyed and pissed off and it breaks
the immersion soda alright here we go
this does not look suspicious at all is
it maybe I should replay the original
game would you guys be down for that
full let's play I don't know if that's
interesting maybe I'll do it for a live
stream haybales you for that
you guys can join along the barrel
I think satisfying me why do you hate us
pimps is it because we're brown we know
you're a racist names
[Music]
maybe I should ask you guys to make a
custom story for next like ready
submission thing
oh no oh not the water my second that's
[ __ ] water
oh my god I have a bone saw how am I
supposed to make it all the way
I didn't even help
[Music]
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it still gets to go and how doesn't it
I'm screaming way too much for this
microphone I'm sorry whoa get your blood
going get your blood going man the
memories the good times we had so much
fun in this game man so much fun the
members they're all coming back to me
they're all coming back it's such a
shame such a damn shame I mean I fully
understand that developers of not
wanting to do this the same game over
and over they want to make the game they
want to make they made a really great
game I just never got around to play
what was called remembered it was called
map I see the hole there behind
No okay nevermind I know there was like
a oh why do I keep picking up bones
there and all the hip spots
I [ __ ] played it so much
wait isn't this where we can forget what
there's blood that's always a great
indicator of where to go this this
doesn't look bad at all
what I haven't seen this room before
that was it was it a Dan Huffman holding
three one four that was a thing they
would add up there each ending they had
a different message at the very end
depending on which ending cuz the game
had three different endings everything
alright well that wasn't that fun to
revisit let me know what you guys think
I think that sort of fits the sort of
fits what it was for what it was I thank
you guys for watching I hope you had fun
at revisiting this with me I had a lot
of fun I'm smiling I can't stop smiling
it's so fun leave a like if you enjoyed
watching I'll see you sisters or Broce